después de un parón de casi seis meses
por la crisis de el coronavirus el museo
de arte moderno de río de janeiro se
abre hoy con una novedad las entradas
son libres es decir cada uno paga lo que
puede lo que quiere o incluso nada que
le parece esta iniciativa el museo me ha
parecido súper interesante muy
importante y cultural
incluso ley que aquí hay una colección
con más de once mil objetos pensaba que
la entrada valdría más valor y alma y
usted hoy pago o no pago o pago no pague
yo pague porque creo que vale mucho yo
pagué 20-30 reales distree para
determinar el museo de más estrena
director es una carioca y un español en
un proyector novedoso para el mundo
artístico brasileño que es una gestión
compartida a qué se debe esta novedad
cuando presentamos nuestra candidatura
para la dirección artística pensamos en
esta posible dinámica de desarrollar una
generación artística con dos goleadas la
inclusión de las minorías también es una
prioridad de esta gestión si queremos
que sea un museo para todas las personas
en el arte y están acostumbrados a
frecuentar museos y aquellas personas
que no están no se sienten bienvenidos
en los museos y vamos a hacer un trabajo
muy fuerte para que esas personas vengan
aquí y se sientan pertenecientes al
lugar por supuesto está haciendo
aplicado un protocolo sanitario que
prevé máscaras distanciamiento social
desinfección de las manos y control de
la temperatura para evitar que ese lugar
de arte se pueda convertir en un lugar
de contagio